the drop stars Tom Hardy James
Gandolfini and Noomi Rapace and what the
stone is about is a drop bar it's a barn
which various criminals can drop their
money and kind of conceal it and hide it
from the authorities and Tom Hardy and
James Gandolfini run this establishment
and when that establishment is robbed
and some of that money is then lost a
whole bunch of dominoes fall over up a
ladder in which one guy doesn't have his
money anymore and that's not a good
thing I was interested in this movie for
a number of reasons for one I thought it
looked really good I loved Tom Hardy I
think he's one of the best actors
working today I also really liked Noomi
Rapace and James Gandolfini
unfortunately passed away and this is
his last role which really sucks because
he is fantastic in this movie and as I
watched this movie I kept thinking to
myself what a fricking tragedy this guy
is a genius actor and he is so good in
this movie I mean there was just so much
you can read on his face and he does
such a great job for traying this
character who has a past and certain
things are broken up about him and you
really feel it in his portrayal and he
is just excellent in this movie as is
Tom Hardy who gives an incredibly
understated performance in this movie
his performance in this movie is so
restrained that once you realize where
his character is going you realize how
brilliant it is this guy is a freaking
amazing actor and he is so good in this
film his character has this seething
boiling rage that he never lets over
flow and when it does overflow this
movie went to another level I really
enjoyed the drop it was a very very good
movie it has a few problems that I'll
talk about later but this movie just
looked so good bright vibrant colors
really nice cinematography excellent
performances and a very very special
script and I say special because this is
one of those movies where it just sort
of shows people talking and it's not
always necessarily about the plot it's
just building character making people
look more like human beings and the drop
takes its time with its characters and
that's something I really liked about
this movie knew Mira Paz is also really
great in this movie as a girl who kind
of helps Tom Hardy take care of a dog
that he finds in a trash can it was a
very sweet relationship I thought they
had great chemistry with one another and
she was terrific in the movie as well
but that script written by Dennis Lehane
who wrote the books like four shutter
island' and mr.
River he does a really good job with
this movie he also wrote the book and he
wrote the script too it does take a
little while it's a little bit too long
to set up the main plot it would have
been nice if there was a little more
energy in this movie for the first actor
so the second a third act really started
to pick up but towards the beginning it
took a while for it to get started and
there were also scenes in the film that
feel very unnecessary like they should
just not really be there for instance
there's a scene where a pretty bad guy
sneaks into nume reponses house and he
surprises her that's scary right but
they show him sneak into her house and
okay so I get it they're setting up that
scene but then then his show I'm eating
a sandwich for like 30 seconds he's just
sitting there
eating a sandwich I'm like why is this
necessary I don't understand I
understand they're kind of building up
that guy's creep factor but it would
have been more frightening if we didn't
know he was in the house and she was
startled by him I guess but at the same
time that's also a bit cliched so I can
understand why they were trying to do
different things with it because there
are times in this movie where there are
similar mobster like elements that
you've seen in other films but the
execution makes it seem different and
that's one of the things I really liked
about the drop it looks good it has
great performances the script is really
good it's just a little bit slow to get
started but once it does and Tom Hardy
really explodes I was really impressed
with the drop and I'm gonna give it a B+
guys thanks so much for watching I hope
you check out the movie and let me know
what you thought below and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck man eyes
Oh